I'll go ahead get five sins out of the
way on this like the last two movies
combined have three mentions of Moscow
Russia as if you have memory loss like
decent bored so the Moscow police are
coming after born because of that tunnel
chase scene from the last movie well the
tip Bourne gets spotted in the first
place and how is he identified by anyone
in that dark ass tunnel hey may be time
to get a disguise or something right now
that borns taking care of the last
movies flashback from his past
here's another flashback that was
apparently waiting in line until the
other flashback finished its business
when it connect to this Brokeback The
Bourne series tries very hard to find as
many old white books as they can to be
the bad guys in these movies so that you
will have a hard time remembering
whether Chris Cooper Brad Cox got Glenn
or Albert Finney's in which movie girl
that he was on the run with Jesus the
first five minutes of this movie is
recapping what happened in the other
movies like a lot and the balls on board
this is his second Breaking and Entering
and telling people how their loved ones
died moment in the past 15 minutes of
boarding someone started on this and I'm
gonna find them doesn't born already
have his necessary revenge the only
person who started all this back up is
Warren Abbott who you might remember is
dead now but that's not enough Bourne
must now kill the guy behind the guy
have you heard about operation black
friar this investigative reporter who
has been researching us black bag ops
that are dangerously secretive decides
to say the name of some secret op word
on his cell phone
Bowens in the newspaper and he's still
not hiding his face at all just enjoy
her out in the open train ride dude his
bones girlfriend really going to be like
bonds girlfriend from Casino Royale
where we spent several movies mourning
the loss moody goes back and forth from
dead girlfriend flashbacks to assassin
training flashbacks with no warning or
reason or connection just a double dose
of plot man I'm gonna walk by you I want
you to move along the far wall to your
left in four three two one
gotta say the scene where Bourne talks
the reporter through this train station
is amazeballs for that we will remove
three centons are the Alice it must be
nice to go to work every day and
basically your job is to say the same
line a different way a hundred times and
get paid for oh you say that's all I do
too well fair enough
well the bin man I think he's one of
them garbage man negative oh Jesus Jesus
he's reaching for something I get that
this guy is freaking out it's his first
time being hunted by assassins but he's
so over the top identify as the trashcan
man as the killer it's laughable
it's like he's seen unbreakable a
hundred times and goes deaf to born in
his ear this guy
god help ya that guy who wrote about
Jason Bourne I wonder who has the
requisite skills to take down some of
your surveillance team in such a
clandestine way hmm maybe you should be
looking for someone who looks like born
born dispatches his enemies through
rapid-fire editing Jesus Christ close
enough
lock all the exits give the asset a
green light can American CIA personnel
block all the exits to a British train
station like legally let alone the
question of manpower
Kella cameras I get there were allies
but would England really give the CIA
direct control of its security cameras
in a highly trafficked public area like
this train station
I don't think so is what I'm saying
Bourne just stay where you are
I'm going towards no no again this
asshole ignores board and acts on panic
resulting in his own death with Johnny I
don't feel all that bad about Bourne
goes after the blackbriar assassin as
though he doesn't remember these guys
are trained to give up nothing and
capturing one would be useless one of
these dudes ran and jumped out a window
rather than dr. Bourne I see that the
CIA didn't bother to check the trains
again and Bourne is walking around in
the open like an asshole you know I'm
willing to believe Bourne is amazing and
not being caught but not in the man of
these movies would have us believe you
have any idea who you're dealing with
this is Jason boy Landy who knew nothing
about Jason Bourne in the last movie and
made these exact same mistakes is now
scolding everyone in this room for not
knowing who Jason Bourne is now maybe
because this is the Deep Cover division
of the CIA they should already know who
he is but that's still a sin for not
surveilling the train stations and
airports for his whereabouts he's
committing treason by talking to Ross do
you really think while doing that he's
gonna use a cell phone that he knows we
can track well maybe a lot of people in
these movies do stupid things all the
time can't hurt to at least track it
right it's kind of great they never show
this magic master key that Bourne uses
I'd like just wants to see it fail and
then see what he does after that power
to the motion sensors just happened to
be right next to the door and out of the
sight line of those sensors this asshole
who took everything out of the seat
before leaving somehow left behind a
photo of himself for pure plotline
purposes I get you want things to be
dramatic it's a movie after all but this
is two guys in the dark with handguns
we've seen Bourne take on and take out
works so why not just hide right inside
the door and jump these fools as opposed
to all this elaborate fan light Bowl I
really like these movies but damn try
following this gang action scene is it
convenient or coincidence that Nikki
from the last two Bourne movies just
happens to currently be working out of
this office and just happened to check
in right now after hours when it's late
and something's going down
not that he's in any danger from Niki
year but seems like borns major
weaknesses phones ringing because he
gets distracted every time she was
Treadstone logistics seems like you guys
would have contacted her since she was
officially moved to Madrid and she's a
born expert and you have a born
operation going down in Madrid my cars
outside I know where Daniels is that's
like two more levels of coincidence
beyond just you being here right now
it's like coincidence to the third power
the only way this could get any more
convenient is if you discovered
ant-man's Pym particle and Daniels is
actually in your purse right now eight
o'clock this morning he wired $100,000
to a bank account in Tangier sure okay
but how do you know about that either
you're his co-conspirator or else you
knew he was a criminal but still didn't
tell the CIA making you a traitor also
the guy who apparently won't be on a
cell phone because he's too smart leaves
a money trail to his next destination he
said you were the first one Daniels did
a lot of blabbing about super top secret
to this girl damn why was he telling her
all this knowledge if it is so dangerous
that vosen wants to kill him it was
difficult for me with you is this movie
saying a bone I think this movie's
saying they boned also never once did
she make it seem like they were an item
in any of the other Bourne movies kind
of like Julia Stiles was never told her
character used to date born until this
movie was made also 22 seconds of oh
you're telling me we used to date
staring you're gonna want to look at
this ah it is the old you better come
take a look at this cliche but wondering
when that one would rear its head in
this movie is in Tangier a newborn was
coming after this Daniels guy but
somehow don't have the same information
that Nicky had about transferring money
to an account earlier this morning and
are just now finding out where he is
Noah vosen there's no good reason to
show you this right now but we'd like
you to have the knowledge of how this
safe works for later in the movie for
Bourne's I'm in your office waiting
which actually only makes this weirder
because Bourne is not watching this safe
and operation right now like we are yet
he will still know that the safe
requires saying no bosun's named break
into it later it just tripped in his
passport to a hotel in Tangier Jesus now
all he has to do is use his cell phone
which he'll never do according to Landy
okay they know two subjects left the
office where they talk to Nicky by phone
so they know she's neither working for
nor is his prisoner
yet it still wasn't CIA a policy to lock
out her logins but to this movie moving
forward hinges on her ability to log in
right now to the CIA computer network
and it's just utterly bonkers that she's
able to do it why would you type
location in the delete search parameter
section and not in the add search
parameter section
oh so they can't find where Daniels is
because it's being blocked by a firewall
but the information has to
would kill Daniels that's perfectly
accessible information asset unscheduled
stop Oh can they differentiate a stop
with a red light do they have a sensor
in that scooter they can tell the motors
been turned off Matt Damon in the Bourne
Ultimatum ripped off this pickpocket
moon from Matt Damon in Ocean's eleven
some jelena authorised breach she
breached you're like ages ago texting
while scootering also okay she gave my
new phone though is he still getting CIA
instructions on his old phone shouldn't
she have asked for his original phone at
the switch does this dude even question
why he got a new phone in the middle of
an operation born by writing this close
to the target he's tailing is a fucking
dumb ass of colossal proportions
I mean it's objects in mirror may be
closer than they appear right and he
appears to be one point five car lengths
behind him so he's basically riding this
guy's ass
- is smarter than born why was the
spin-off given to jeremy renner instead
of motherfucking - man oh yeah he's
about to die I forgot but still - rules
the blast killed Daniels in his car but
Jason Bourne no surprise is barely
affected by the blast of which he took
the brunt well now isn't this the most
convenient broken sidewalk turned into a
motorcycle ramp I've ever seen in my
life okay at this point Bourne seems to
have lost desh and now sees the cops
coming for him so he goes up to the
roofs of Tangier and then somehow finds
- again street vendors selling like
hairspray when there just happens to be
a fire nearby that that hairspray could
be thrown into I mean it's like Morocco
was built for this chase scene that was
some quick thinking by born to steal
those people's clothes so that he could
scale this wall that had glass on it I
wonder how he knew that was going to
happen they've entered one of those
apartment complexes where for some
reason you could always hear a baby
crying in the distance in this total
maze of apartments and rooftops Bourne
just happens to see Nikki at a window
just before she's about to get killed
gotta say this fight is pretty
exhilarating even though it's got a lot
of cuts in it it's well lit in tight
quarters and it's a tense gotta remove
us in for this right we'll roll it up
hang it around her neck and start over
what the shady boss played by Scott
Glenn is evil I would never get I can
see the faces every whenever killed
born says this at the exact moment Landy
just happens to be looking at all the
people borns ever killed Nikki had to
cut and dye her hair but Bourne
continues with his normal Matt Damon he
saw moody steals something from vertigo
or single white female or something like
that
one of those West's effect the most
onion completely and totally amazing the
CIA didn't get to Daniel's belongings
first despite all logic borne somehow
talks himself into the morgue to see
Daniels body in the same city where he's
a wanted man being chased across
rooftops a few hours ago amazing he's
like James Bond meets Houdini really his
bomb exploded everything except an
extremely useful address in fact it
seems like it did it on purpose and does
Jason Bourne seriously need this burned
piece of paper to find out where the
Deep Cover CIA Building is in New York
seriously couldn't have just asked Nikki
before we put her on a bus but whatever
a cool burned paper shot yo hem you need
to see this there you are again you
rascally rabbit up a cliche I see you I
got you
they don't know Landy is referring to
the blackbriar bad guys who yes should
very well know this little scope allows
you to spy into CIA offices in full
hi-def now if you're telling me the
device somehow x-rays through tinted
glass and shows a perfect view of the
room why doesn't it show the officers
below NOAA's office right now also no
one just happens to be in his office
doing some shady at this very moment
here we go to situation another come
take a look at this cliche would it not
be more prudent to say borns talking to
Landy right fucking now dude than
whatever you said
get some rest man you look tired man
these movies really love whammy I'm
watching you phone conversations even
when it's not a whammy anymore after the
scene was done in the last movie Noah
vosen Wow good thing this guy answers
his personal cell phone the same way he
opens his safe I'm sitting in my office
I doubt that Bourne managed to slip by
everyone get into Noah's office because
he's born I guess either that or this
division is continuing their comically
stupid journey through this movie Plus
no one ever walks by the office and sees
a strange man in there if you were in
your office right now we'd be having
this conversation face-to-face I see why
Bourne says this so that Noah will
divert all his attention back to the
office and get them off Landy so that he
can meet her at 4:15 71st Street my
question is after getting nowhere to say
his name why didn't you just hang up
steal the files and call again from
another location because this gives the
CIA a good idea of where he is causing
all the mayhem in the world he shouldn't
survive such an onslaught even though of
course he does although I guess these
recorders are clear enough that they
capture perfect tone and frequency from
the speaker of a cell phone and don't
sound like somebody talking on a phone I
want everyone back in the vehicles as a
code cat aboard forget totally about
land II who has obviously gone rogue and
is in league with Warren forget about
putting just two agents on her to follow
her just in case Bourne might not be
where he claims he is forget that he's
so far been playing tons of games with
you and that this is probably yet
another diversionary tactic I mean Jesus
this dude not in the car get down to
this level so fast and become an ex
machina the fast in the morning is third
sir take a look at this oh my god this
movie which I love in a door has set the
record for the most you got to take a
look at this moments in a single film
yeah no idea what's going on which might
be attributed to the camera work by
shakes the clam I mean this is a major
wreck the second one borns had in five
minutes they did not give him adamantium
bones did they third major wreck in five
minutes still nothing here gentlemen
this is a priority-one situation why
didn't anyone make any calls to this
place and tell them to watch out for
this guy Jason Bourne backups on the way
why did you pick me you really don't
remember then why do people keep asking
him this this line of dialogue is now
officially accounted for 1% of this
movie's runtime so this is actually a
pretty good scene and everything tells
us where Jason Bourne came from and
fills in a lot of gaps but do we really
need these this is a flashback streaks
going through the film and the dialogue
echoes to tell us that it's a flashback
I mean Jesus can we just watch this
normally for once
jumps out of a window that I assumed he
knew wouldn't cause him to fall to his
death Bourne will also survive this
making me now believe I'm watching some
sort of religious movie about God or a
god this guy's been unconscious in the
water so long he should have drowned by
now oh that's not right
hey did you just take his wallet he just
took that guy's wallet okay Tucker with
me and we'll see you sheets on the
sidewalk you know what I hate about
myself I know what people taste like
Pamela Landy I told you not to hang up
on me
should be a TV show about a guy who
calls home one day and he's there he
answers he's talking to himself only at
someone else he's somehow divided into
two and the second one of him drives
away and the rest of the show is about
him trying to find the guy
sir II drove off the roof watch these
wine on top you chose right here to
become